denise and bryan centennial center still
remains popular among voters on election
day
you can see the line here behind me it
is
spilling into the overflow area as it
snakes through the parking lot here by
home depot but anyone who wants to come
to this site to cast their ballot
don't let this line intimidate you
voters tell me it's taking between 20 to
30 minutes to get to the front
and it seems social distancing among
those in line makes it seem
longer but the line here is a fairly
familiar sight this election
this was the most popular early voting
site in clark county
nearly 27 thousand people cast a ballot
here in october
one voter i spoke with today says seeing
the early turnout made her want to wait
until
election day we came by a few times and
i'm like
i was going to do it the first time ever
early voting and we came by and i was
like
oh man mackenzie the lines were really
long i go we're just going to wait and
go on tuesday
like my plan to anyway but yeah it was
crazy
there are 40 voting machines inside the
tent all have been working fine so far
according to the election leader here
there are also 26 election workers
assisting voters
now as you can see metro police are out
here this is the second time they
visited this location this evening
they were first called due to someone
campaigning on private property i'm told
that was resolved very easily
they have come back here due to someone
seeming to
make some of the poll workers a little
uncomfortable but they
are saying they're going around to all
the various sites tonight just to make
sure
everything is ok now if you do want to
cast your ballot here
make sure you are in line by 7 o'clock
and if you were registered to vote in
nevada and have that mail-in ballot
you can fill it out as well and come
here to the site to just
drop it off reporting live in the
northwest valley kristen drummond 8 news
now